can art has decided to set up their
packaging subscriber as a service
containerized up on cloud run keep
watching to find out how
[Music]
in the last episode we learned about the
different options and authentication
methods that cloud pub/sub supports for
push message delivery we also set up
cloud functions as the push subscriber
endpoint today let's setup cat outs
packaging subscriber application on
service platform cloud run but before we
do that cloud run and cloud functions
are both serverless so when should you
use one over the other
well cloud functions are great for
event-driven applications you deploy
code as functions I call them via HTTP
request or set it to trigger based on a
background event but it is possible that
for some services you need more control
over the execution environment and the
language or you're already running the
service in a container in such cases you
would want to setup the service on cloud
run which enables you to package code in
a stateless container then invoke it via
HTTP requests so today let's help cat
out set a packaging service as a push
subscriber and point on cloud run to get
set up login to the Google Cloud console
select your project and open cloud shell
if you've not already played with Python
talk samples then clone the app
repository using git clone then CD into
the folder we just downloaded and go to
run and then pops up then launch the
editor so we can see the code for our
application in the Explorer on the Left
find the folder for Python samples and
go to run and pops up let's see what's
going on here
main dot py has the server setup that
handles incoming requests then there's
the handler that processes the pub/sub
message and logs a greeting hello world
and it's also returning a 204 response
code remember from the last episode the
subscriber needs to respond back with
success codes such as 200 204 etc
because it acts as an acknowledgment for
the complete processing of the message
and if we return HTTP error codes such
as 400 or 500 that indicates that the
message will be retried and of course
the docker file that defines the
operating environment for the service
the contents of the docker file will of
they weary by the language of your
choice now in order to push this code to
cloud run we need to build a container
push it to container registry and then
deploy it so let's head on over to our
cloud shell and we will use g-cloud
build submit with tag GC r dot IO slash
project name slash service name we will
see a success with the source and the
image address now we are ready to deploy
and for that we execute the command G
cloud run deploy the name of the service
which in this case is packaging service
and provide the image address which is
GC r dot io slash project ID slash
container name for this example I'm
choosing cloud run fully managed option
but you can't select anthos to select
the region i picked us central here we
have to say no to the allow
authenticated prompt because we only
want pops up to access the packaging
service once it is deployed we have the
service URL when we click on it it leads
us to forbidden this is expected since
we said no to the unauthenticated front
at this point we have the packaging
service now how do we integrate this
service with pub/sub so our order topic
can send messages to the packaging
subscriber well let's see we go to I am
and enable pub/sub to create
authentication tokens in our project we
locate the cloud pub/sub service account
and add a role service account token
creator to it
then we create the service account to
represent the pub/sub subscription
identity for that we go to service
accounts in iam and create a new service
account now we will give the invoker
service the account permissions it needs
to invoke our packaging service for this
we use g-cloud run service ad iam policy
binding the name of our service which we
called packaging service the member
which is our service account and the
role is invoker now we create the pubsub
subscription for our packaging service
with this service account we execute the
command G cloud pub/sub subscriptions
create provide the name of the
subscription topic that we want to be
associated with in our case it's our
topic the push endpoint needs to be our
cloud run service
URL and the pushed odd service account
flag activates the pub/sub pushed
functionality for authentication and
authorization we go to pops up and see
that our subscription is created with
that Cal's packaging service is fully
integrated with pub/sub and we are ready
to send a message from or a publisher to
our packaging subscriber and to verify
that our cloud run packaging subscriber
received it we go to the logs in stat
driver and filter on cloud run and we
see that the messages received so there
you have it we just setup an integration
between cloud pub/sub and cloud run
alright so today we helped cat out
deploy a push subscriber on cloud run
and receive messages from the order
service using cloud pub/sub stay tuned
for the next episode where we will help
cat out replay and porridge messages
until then give us a like subscribe and
let us know what you want to learn about
our parser
[Music]
you